let's talk about you mentioned what's
the result of women you know what are
women going to experience now with these
guidelines and a loss of toxic
masculinity are with a loss of
traditional masculinity I don't know if
you want to elaborate on you know what
you meant or what you think I just have
questions because if these masculine
traits are the equivalents of a mental
disorder then what does that mean for my
daughter got a thirteen-year-old
daughter
so what if she finds herself attracted
to traditionally masculine men men who
know how to contain their emotions and
show a little leadership and have a
social network and a sense of humor and
they have all these things that are sort
of associated with toxic masculine or
toxic masculinity what does that say to
her that she's attracted to this and
what does it say that you're gonna have
men that are that are squashing these
qualities within themselves and trying
to be more feminized and more
domesticated for lack of a better term
more tame you know is this are they are
tame men sexy uh no tell me why they're
not saying because I don't know because
they're not going to go out there
they're probably not going to be able to
change the tire they're not gonna know
what to do in a scary situation I think
I think you're you know sexualizing it
too much yeah I think you know what's
what's the more visceral and emotive
reaction to tame men I don't know gross
yeah it's gross it's kind of it is kind
of a visceral I'm not interested no no
not at all and and this is one of the
one of the problems I think when it
comes to the result on women is that you
end up with a bunch of guys you know the
meme of the nice guy mm-hmm right so so
you there's actually sub this there's
online forms dedicated to mocking these
people you'll see like I'll send a
message saying hello m'lady how are you
I am a fancy gentleman I'm a nice guy
and it's like cringe cringe cringe and
then when the woman says well I'm an
interstate he says well screw you you're
a disgusting you know slaw blah blah I
feel like that behavior is a result of
stripping away traditional masculinity
for one they're not stomach at all they
snap at a moment they lose what they
wanted they're faking pretending to be
this tame you know demure man or
whatever to attract a woman and then we
don't get they want they explode they
can't control themselves
yeah and I have a friend Robert Glover
he's wrote a book called know
mr. nice guys a very very well-received
book he's probably a lot of people in
the audience have read this and he makes
the point that nice guys aren't really
nice and he's you know he he started
doing this work long before on the APA
guidelines and so forth it's he's been
around for a few decades and he's been
working with men and his basic premise
is that the nice guy that you know the
toxically nice guy he has a covert
contract with the world that nobody
knows about but if I'm a nice guy my
assumption is that if I'm nice to
everybody around me and I rescue the
damsel in distress and I'm the one that
everybody complains to and so if I just
take it all on that the world will treat
me kindly in return but it doesn't work
that way and so the nice guys get the
opposite experience they're nice to the
world the night the world is not nice
back to there so the covert contract has
been violated and now they're angry and
I think that the APA is is creating a
recipe for women being unhappy with men
they're creating a recipe for more of
these false nice guys that aren't really
nice because once they feel like that
contract has been violated then they get
bitter then they start being
passive-aggressive and and I'm not I'm
not talking about doing violent things
necessarily but just being kind of turds
in life and I'm good to the people
around them well they're not gonna be so
so I think it's funny when they say that
you know women like a-holes we don't
swear here on YouTube that I've heard
this so much when I was growing up where
you'd find these air-quote nice guys
saying like that women really just like
jerks and then they think the reaction
is to be mean and nasty and I'm like you
don't really get it do you in my
experience and you're the expert so
correct me if I'm wrong but my
experience sometimes I am a jerk I'm
arrogant narcissistic sometimes
absolutely but typically I'm not I'm
just stern focused I'm driven and I know
what I want I know what I want to get
I'll do right by you if you do right by
me and sometimes I'll tell you to shut
up because you're wrong so you would be
considered disagreeable to some extent
so there's the the big five personality
traits that Jordan Peters has made them
very famous cuz he talks about them a
lot but it's a wonderful construct for
for thinking about a human personality
and it's wonderful because it has tons
of data behind it so the the the traits
are openness conscious
business extraversion agreeableness and
neuroticism so agreeableness is
something that traditionally masculine
men tend to be a little bit lower on and
it's actually one of the things that
women generally find attractive about a
man because they have the trace that
you're talking about in yourself the
ability to say no to somebody the
ability to defend your values and by the
way that's the opposite of the nice guy
right not examiner looking for the the
a-hole they're looking for the guy who
can stand up for his beliefs stand up
for her go after what he wants in life
and so part of that is being a little
bit disagreeable when it's necessary not
for the zakat which you strike me as
somebody who could be disagreeable when
it's necessary right and and and so what
ends up happening is you know and again
I credit a lot of this to skateboarding
because you know what I've dealt with
the pain I've done with the broken bones
and so I became very confident in myself
but I also became very understanding of
how much it hurts when you mess up so I
understand the fear I understand you
know what people go through and so when
it came to you know dating and stuff my
attitude is very much like if you say
something dumb I'm gonna tell you what's
dumb hmm
so that creates a perception that
sometimes you're a jerk but then these
nice guys who are completely agreeable
they don't they're not decisive they
don't tell women you know where they
want to eat they say whatever you say
whatever you want and that's in my
experience I've seen men failing when
they try and do things like this but I
think when you look at the way the woke
feminism and like the APA the way
they're trying to make men it's like
they're pushing them into the nice guy
corner where they have to act this way
right which is dangerous what happens
when they do everything they're told and
they get the opposite reaction
yeah what happened they get bitter and
resentful yeah and so I don't answer
this is put you in a weird position but
um have you wouldn't because you tell me
no right yeah you tell me I don't want
to answer that right oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I want I don't need to qualify this
by saying don't answer you don't want to
the best of your ability to be objective
about it how do you think women respond
to your assertive
sometimes disagreeable nature positively
what do you mean I mean like there's a
reason why I'm an arrogant prick because
you're not an arrogant prick but I'm
exaggerating right I'm I'm being a bit
soft deprecating
and I think this is another part of it
too it's kind of like it in in my
experience it is a bit diffusing when I
acknowledge or or say like yeah mom I'm
a dick and I know it and it's kind of
like well you can be so at least you
know I don't know in my experience I
grew up as a rather cocky arrogant young
person who was good at everything and
when I would skate I was I was always
really good not necessarily the best but
I certainly thought I was and so what
happens is when my interactions with
other people and obviously when I was
younger I was you know often
insufferable for sure I'll be the first
to admit it but it because I was very
confident thought so highly of myself
mostly because and again I credit
skateboarding I'd be willing to jump off
a six-foot high you know land a ledge of
some sort fall on the ground roll get
hurt and I knew I was tough I knew I was
confident so I'd absolutely no problem
walking it up someone and being like hey
how's it going but I was hanging out the
park I couldn't I noticed you you want
to you want to go hang out I got nothing
else to do mmm cuz I look man I've
fallen down I've broken bones I am
absolutely not scared to talk to you and
say what I want to say and if she said
no back later nice meeting you nothing
bothers me whatever and so for me when I
would be more sort of like here's where
I want to go eat if you don't want to
come I don't tell you today I want
deep-dish pizza well and they say I
don't want to beat some but I'm gonna
get I'm going to get devious pizza you
can come if you want mmm and typically
it's like okay and things tend to work
out positively in that regard I eat I'll
put it this way I think highly of myself
and I do what I want to do and no one's
gonna get my way so if I wake up and say
I know for sure I want to go to the
hibachi place down the street you're
probably not gonna convince me not to do
so but I'm not a complete prick right if
you are like look man I know you really
really want to go but I've been dying to
go to this place do me this favor I'd
say okay okay so you you've laid out
that you are perfectly willing to ask
for what you want in life so can I ask
Lydia what how she thinks women respond
to this this cycle all right yeah yeah
what do you think how do women respond
to this side of it
I appreciate this honestly personally
when it comes to our interactions at
work it's like if I made a mistake I'm
gonna know about it and I would
infinitely rather know that I messed up
or that something is wrong then be not
sure where I stand and to be kind of out
on the edge okay so that's in a
professional context what about any in a
social romantic context how do you think
women respond to this side of his person
socially to have somebody who's like
well here's I'm gonna do you gonna come
with me if I think it's great because
women are very indecisive and you need
someone who's like here's what we're
gonna do
here's what I'm thinking you know give
me a two cents you know we'll do
whatever you want to do but this is what
I was thinking I have a plan you know I
have something that I wanted to do come
on with me so you're saying that women
have internalized toxic fescue I have
been told that I have entire
internalized misogyny so that might just
be that coming out to plan it I really
know or maybe it's that women in general
tend to like men who in general can
assert themselves yeah I would say
that's definitely true and here's the
thing though I don't really look at it
that way like I'm trying to assert
myself I just I want to do what I want
to do if you know I that's the
definition of being right confident
right because you're not checking in
with anybody else to ask is it okay if I
do what I want to do you're just doing
what you want to do that yeah finition
it gets me in trouble sometimes but it
leads to success sure so you know I
remember when I worked for I'm not gonna
name media companies but everybody knows
where I worked
Iram I was working for some company that
was absolutely convinced they were the
best and everyone was dying to work for
them and so when I quit their jaws at
the floor like why would you quit we're
the best and I said no I'm the best so
I'm leaving and to them it was kind of
shocking but I was like listen the one
thing I want to explain to you guys is
that I don't work for you you work for
me
you're the billion dollar corporation I
get it that's how you view it that's
fine it's your business you do what you
want but I'm here because you're giving
me money to do the things I want to do
the moment you stop doing that I leave
because you are now no longer part of my
plan and they were like congratulations
you know we look forward to seeing what
you accomplished okay so let me ask
Lydia a question this this um
this ethic that he's describing here
where he approaches the world this way
do you think that that this is something
that's missing in or not the president
no she's not and by the way and I didn't
finish a question about it is it not
present enough in the millennial
generation absolutely I think this is
hugely missing because the the inability
to face an adventure and to tackle a
challenge is crippling and I think
that's half the reason that men are so
reticent because they haven't had a good
role models maybe because they've been
feminized in school because schools
never been good to them and they've been
they've been trying to cash this bad
check of being a nice guy and it's made
them resentful cash the bad check out
yeah bad check it is because then you
become resentful you've been nice now
it's the world doing for you here's the
thing though if you know for good or for
better for worse if I have everyone
pointing the finger at me and saying
you're bad you're awful I would not care
mmm like might you know it's it's funny
to me because I think about where I am
today and I'm like you know I'm like I'm
really happy that I worked really really
hard work I have no days off I literally
work every single day and I have
technical half days off on the weekends
when we don't do this podcast now cuz I
I'm crazy I guess but I was thinking
about it now I'm like I've never really
sat down and thought that I've I'm proud
of where I've gotten where I finally
made it or accomplished anything because
the same way I feel today is the same
way I felt when I was an 18 year old
homeless kid walking around with the
skateboard I just was always like I'm
the best this is great I know what I'm
doing I know what I want to do it
nobody's gonna get in my way and so when
it was me riding my skateboard around
downtown Chicago minding my own business
enjoying myself looking up at the sky
with a smile on my face saying nothing's
gonna get me down and that's the ethos
that kind of I think helps me be
successful yeah and so what got you here
is not what the APA prescribed exactly
well so I guess the the bigger question
then is you brought up the Millennial
thing I think it's a really important
thing because I love ragging on
Millennials because when you asked is
this missing well I know Lidia agrees
but I certainly do too I look at my
generation and many of the men are whiny
not all of them but many of the men are
whiny you know unaccomplished timid weak
scared low self-esteem yeah and I think
part of it is school you know you
mentioned that schools of is it more
feminine environment is that how you
described it yeah I didn't go I went I
went to grade school
Finnick graduated eighth grade and then
about two months of high school and then
I left saying I refuse I absolutely
refuse to be a part of this and so I was
like you know was really intersting to
me because one day I was I was just
miserable and I thought to myself
literally what will they do if I don't
go to school nothing like what's the
worse it's gonna happen
I don't care schools were so yeah you're
not going to jail yeah one of the things
I've noticed about you and forgive me
because I you know I watch people yeah
yeah yeah yeah one of the things I've
noticed about just this short time that
we've been together today is you have
people around you that that appear to
love you and I'm not saying they're
being obsequious but I'm saying I come
into this place everybody's relaxed
everybody's calm everybody's doing their
thing and moving the ship in the in the
same direction and so you being the
quintessential toxic man male and you
bring all this masculine energy to this
this world that you've created here and
I don't know it seems like the people
around you seem to be pretty happy and
I'm sure they've been plenty of people
that said this guy's not for me right
you being forthright allows them to make
that choice and then go someplace else
where they fit in better so toxic
masculinity I don't know it seems to be
working out for you personally and
professionally do it do I have that
right yes but but the way I see it is it
doesn't matter that you're so toxic if
everybody hated my young to go into
recovery we need to get you into 12-step
because you were so toxic I am
absolutely toxic and the funny thing is
I think as other people have described
this house is a commune it's like I live
with a bunch of my friends and there's
now like four or five people hanging out
and I'm very as much as it was the
funniest thing to me is I'm I'm such a
hippie I run my business in a horribly
anti-capitalistic way but I'm very
successful in a capitalist system
ideologically though
like I probably I don't want to I want
to give away too much because I don't
want to infringe on other people's you
know private business but yeah I think
it I I could run this in a much more
laissez-faire capitalist way and make a
lot more for myself and I'm not super
interested in that kind of thing I'm
more interested in my mission as long as
I have what I need I'm willing to take
care of everybody else too and we'll
call it a more fair degree than society
would normally dictate right yes so so
this is the other side of toxic
masculinity is this this leadership that
you're providing you're clearly the
leader here and you're clearly providing
people for people and you clearly are
affectionate toward them that but I
slightly disagree okay hope so you know
my buddy Adam for instance normally
doesn't show with me I mean I think it's
fair to say that when it comes to
producing a podcast I have a ton of
experience more than he does but I
always try to explain to people we used
to play this game called the division
and it's it takes place in a in a semi
post-apocalyptic America after plague
wipes everybody out and I would explain
to people it's not so much about who's
the leader all the time it's about who's
leading at the particular moment so when
we play this game there are different
missions like zones and when we would
have it's like four players Adam would
be like hey guys I want to do this I'm
gonna talk like follow me and we'd like
you got it and we wouldn't even ask a
question it would literally be like Adam
would just assert himself and say hey
guys can you equip this and then go
around this side there's a guy gonna
come out you got it we just do it if it
got to a point where we wiped too much
it kept losing someone else would be
like let me try this oh you got it so it
wasn't that any one of us is the leader
so much as there are specific things
some people are experts on and others
aren't like we just went to a sporting
goods store and I was like Adam you take
you tell me what we need to get I have
no idea so this is the kind of subtlety
and I'm getting tired of ragging on the
APA maybe yeah we'll talk about dating
this is the kind of subtlety that the
APA doesn't understand about masculine
and everything about this this very
thing that you're talking about that men
have this ability for men who are well
developed have this ability to step in
and out of leadership positions and it
may not even be a formal role it may be
like wait you're talking about you go to
the sporting goods store he knows the
terrain so he just sort of naturally
fills yeah yeah just takes the lead
there
that sort of subtle ability to step in
and out and have a lot of nonverbal
communication GPS is very big on we need
to communicate the way women communicate
they don't understand the way we
communicate non-verbally so this being
you I'm just holding you up as exhibit a
of toxic masculinity totally and and how
it works and and I'm gonna stop putting
under the microscope cause I don't
disrespect them I don't care thank you
like you could literally call me all
names in the book they call Adam soy bro
and he laughs about it yeah and I'm like
dude if he was the kind of guy who would
get all whiny and cringy because someone
called him a name he probably wouldn't
be hanging out with me like we were
because I'd call him the name too but
he's like he's a confident charismatic
guy who knows what he would you know so
we get along and the same is true for
the people I surround myself with I do
not you know what I can't stand is I
grew up watching shows where you have
losers and that's I'm not trying to be
mean or anything but it's mind-numbing
to me so losers like Homer Simpson is
that which you know Homer Simpson's a
winner man that dudes a [ __ ] but he
just he's got attractive wife he's got a
beautiful family they did that episode
where Frank Grimes is like how does this
guy keep winning and that's hilarious so
what's the loser then so like Al Bundy
okay I can't I couldn't stand it he was
just miserable all the time
there was only one episode I remember
where he actually succeeded he he got he
punched a guy in the face and then sued
him for breaking his hand on his face
because it was making a like the show
was very you know very much but I'm like
I was miserable to watch I I also just
liked that character because he had so
much potential he had a sense of humor
he was a big good-looking guy he could
do whatever he wanted and yeah he was
just so pathetic I grew up watching
shows the shows that inspired me were
the people who refused to give up never
back down and so maybe it's because I
grew up watching like anime shows where
they in tagging it the protagonist
always becomes stronger refuses to back
down always pulls ahead never loses
except for Pokemon that was a terrible
show by the way that was like the one
show like you probably know a whole lot
about this stuff but basically you're
familiar with Pokemon I know what they
write in the original show the main
character just lost all the time and I'm
like I don't want to watch this
but then you have Dragonball Z where the
main character no matter what no matter
how bad the odds were he always did
whatever he had to even sacrificing
himself to succeed and to protect his
family and his friends and that's what
was inspiring to me yeah so yeah I think
that kind of pop culture
superheroes you know thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you